[موسيقى]
علاوه على ذلك شهدت ميزانيه الدفاع في
بولندا زياده والخطه الاساسيه كانت ترتكز
على مقاربه تدريجيه بدءا بزياده الميزانيه
لنحو اثنين في المئه من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي وهي النسبه التي تم تحديدها من
قبل حلف الناتو لكننا نرغب في تحقيق زياده
في ميزانيه الدفاع تصل الى ثلاثه في المئه
من الناتج المحلي وهي زياده هائله وهذه
كلها تطورات ناجمه عن الاحداث التي نشهدها
حاليا
[موسيقى]
وقد ابرمنا صفقه لشراء اثنتين طائره من
طراز 35 وسوف نسلم اوكرانيا 20 طائره من
طراز 29 كما وقعنا عقدا لشراء خمسه
واربعين طائره حربيه من كوريا الجنوبيه
واشترينا طائرات مسيره من طراز بيرقدار من
تركيا ونستخدم ايضا طائرات مسيره حصلنا
عليها من الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
ووقعنا كذلك عقدا لشراء قمرين صناعيين
فرنسيين الى جانب عقد اخر لشراء منظومه
راجمات صواريخ ونحو الف دبابه من كوريا
الجنوبيه هذا جهد جبار يبذل في اطار تحديث
الجيش البولندي
من الاسلحه التي تحتاج اليها بولندا لا
تصلها بالطبع بين عشيه وضحاها بل يتم
تسليمها على المدى القريب والمتوسط
والبعيد بالنظر الى تلبيه متطلبات التدريب
والاحتياجات اللوجستيه الاخرى على سبيل
المثال لن نحصل على 250 دبابه ابرمز دفعه
واحده وانما سوف يتم تسليم هذه الدبابات
الى بولندا على دفعات
[موسيقى]